citizens to the reject Nation it is time
to
shh that means we're watching hush Mike
Flanagan 2016 hush it's what really put
him on the map before all those TV shows
that we know and love uh it's Ron joxie
today
Jay oh you broke my valve silence just
then Ron jocks he's back in the hot seat
yeah you can't be silent when you're on
jaxy and nah dude not when you're
dropping boys back in the building 100
true I hope you like this movie I hope
we like this movie it's supposed to be a
good one and Mike is my my guy I'm a I'm
a Mikey gal so I'm a flanigai
so much cooler than mine yeah they're
they're eager leave a comment like
subscribe let us know if you are hushed
throughout this whole thing actually
don't be hushed right things be vocal
with us because that's the point of a
reaction okay okay yeah what what are
you little John right now that's my role
for this whole reaction I'll be making
three comments great I hope you're
hushed the entire time except for that
oh except for the fact that you're gonna
be a Comic-Con that is that is a fact we
are Saturday we got a panel Saturday
afternoon 1 p.m red coin is gonna be fun
maybe even a Roxy appearance you know I
might stop by we're on some kind of cat
years who knows why and don't forget
also to go over to patreon if you want
to see more of us you want to see more
of the video the whole thing then you
can be a super sexy reject all right
should we do it let's do it
[Music]
what's your prediction for how long it's
silent in this movie
it's an excellent question
give it 10 minutes
well I lost the bet Roxy walked right
into that one I'm just gonna say 45
minutes
you would have won
it's a lovely Cabin in the Woods I
wonder how many people rented this we're
like something's wrong
making a feast
how much for a rib one rib
so this is the first we saw her before
Hill House might be they're married you
know are they really yeah
cool way of showing that she's deaf
that's a nice perspective switch
gosh I'm supposed to respond to her [__]
I said waiting on John so
it's often what people text about me
I actually love that she's in there as
Sarah next door it's how real people
save people's numbers yeah
oh who's that
there's a cat yeah
that's a forest neighborhood cat it's a
wild cat yeah she's doing a service all
right it could be out there devouring
someone's puggle right now
foreshadowing
oh that's a I don't know but I know I
know her
we'll figure it out comment below
another Triple H situation she's a
wrestler yes getting warmer
I finished your book
I know you can read my lips but I'm
getting better better
I want to practice taking another class
with John it's fun and we're better at
understanding than actually doing it
it's true I can vouch for them I tried
to guess the ending I'm usually on point
with that sort of thing but I was way
off I'm always on point
that sort of thing
makes me crazy foreshadowing
I find like the right
ending to connect to the right story
does the voice sound like a kid
you were 13 when you got sick
I think they say 50 of us think in voice
yeah and certain people don't have an
internal yeah I think that you are a
good
Storyteller she's in his Mike's other
stuff that's how I know her
[Laughter]
[Music]
those are very different
yeah I was gonna say you left all that
stuff cooking
oh boy not the cat this things rattle
your brains
yeah it's like a burglar alarm
well I imagine that would wake anybody
yeah that's handy Jesus though how much
sound that must be I was in The Miracle
Worker in high school and they we took
some sign language oh yeah yeah remember
any of it a little bit because it's the
most beautiful language of all time
truly oh who's Craig
someone who's thinking of her obviously
dude and hey she's got so many friends
reading that book I do not think Craig's
a good guy I think you're misreading
that Craig
there's a reason she deleted it yeah
because he's just too good now she can't
live up to that yeah why put yourself
through that you know so it works you're
right that's what makes us women's right
he's not gonna kick the door in by the
end of the movie the next Midnight Mass
Easter eggs oh my God wait so is this
before so is midnight mass oh it's way
before midnight mass because it's 2016.
midnight mass was during the pandemic I
think so and before that was Haunting of
Hill House and blind Manor yeah is
midnight mass like canonically supposed
to be based on this book is she a writer
of monologues I don't know but Mike
Flanagan's the IT guy dude it's Andy
muschietti actually because he directed
it oh
but I know what you meant I was like I
know it's just being a horror goof on
you do I have it I'm sorry I wasn't
listening what the church to Aaron the
church to Father Paul bring in Aaron's
the rage bubbled up spreading into his
head his ears ring his eyes felt hot
whose voice do you think she hears she
said it sounds like her mother that's
better he needs something more
something's okay better Aaron dies can't
kill Aaron oh piss him all off didn't
set it up
this is a great internal monologue this
is very real
call Craig which Craig is going to be
it's Craig Robinson
you know boy
oh no he got a ring that's worse you did
you let it ring through twice girl dude
don't you oh okay okay
no no
no
babe dude you're trapped no no you hate
to see it
you never yeah
no no no no
[Music]
and that's the last we'll hear of Craig
this is a perfectly good sauce
concoction
is it looks like a gravy of some kind
yeah knock on the door she's not gonna
eat anything
oh
[Music]
Jesus punch through yeah that's glass
Howie whoa is it an arrow
bummer
I feel like
vibrations ouch
oh God it's like a Scream movie
this feels like a ghost-facy kind of kid
that mask is really creepy yeah
sometimes the masks in these movies look
goofy to me this one does not look goofy
it's a fine art the iconic horror mask
or the creepy horror mask
pick up maybe he'll see something huh
uh I got the Flash and I'll come back
later
[Music]
[Laughter]
huh
it
brilliant
[Music]
oh shazbear hey squish
did you talk to him
it's been a year mom keeps asking when
you're getting back out there she wants
grandchildren
look at you
it's not good for anyone to be alone
squish no
who is that
oh damn behind you thought I saw
something move
[__] [__] ass cat interview
I wonder how the deaf Community feels
about her signage I know that she's
obviously not a deaf actress I'm curious
the reception this movie had yeah she's
doing a great job for my eyes but I
don't know and how much Super
powerfication will there be what's that
well you know just like how much are
they gonna make it some kind of like
super power oh oh yeah well I mean she
didn't notice him at the door so I don't
think much yeah she clearly didn't get
like super sight
yeah that like I can sense any vibration
in the air she's Daredevil you never
know
let's get that woozy tracking shot
you're probably able to shoot this for
not that expensive too I love these one
house things that are done well yeah
creepy
[__] you think [__] is dead where are
you [__] I'm gonna say no not yet but
by the end of the movie I don't know man
maybe we live in a time where it could
go either way so here are the other
characters that we could still come and
help John yes Craig John and Craig are
going to show up [__] John Craig and
[__] are all gonna show up as like a
buddy cop team
oh cause he took her phone
oh
[Music]
okay what are you doing this moment Burn
It Down
you message your sister and say SOS 911
help yeah
oh geez
the game is a foot
oh no
no
[Music]
it's like at this point she doesn't know
her bestie or her neighbor has been
murdered so also she doesn't know what
like is here to rob me is he willing to
kill me
uh
crossbow it feels a little bit like
you're next I wonder who's under that
mask he is like very telling eyes yeah
can can you FaceTime 9-1-1 can uh damn
it
and if you had your phone you could do a
hotspot
start guessing babe
[Music]
yeah you got the Goosebumps that's
authentic
know how much a tire costs like 800
bucks
he's got nice ass tires he's slashing
for them I bet it's gonna be more than
that yep it's game time babe you can do
this oh he's gonna leave him a message
I think it's for hammer for if they find
her
[Music]
won't tell didn't see face
boyfriend coming home
I was like yeah I hope so
oh he's gonna show her his face
wow
she doesn't know him okay I recognize
him too I can come in anytime I want and
I can get you anytime I want uh but I'm
not going to not until it's time when
you wish you're dead that's when I'll
come inside wow nod your head if you
understand me
let me see you nudge here I'm actually
really glad they had him lose his mask
yeah it was a nice usually makes
somebody less scary this made him
significantly more scary well yeah
because it's just a guy
some lunatic and then it doesn't become
a game of who's under the mask yeah it's
what's that guy gonna do
get a couple
[Music]
just wonder why they introduced John as
a concept though if we're not going to
see him at any point I think we've got
it right especially because what
happened with Sarah right now I'm like
yeah those guys are gonna add to the
body cameras
God what a nightmare
really good simple setup to this
[Music]
no no no do not look do not look
whoa all right well it looks like a
jacked up hand is that her home girl oh
I food home girls
oh gross right you're right oh no
oh no don't drop the knife that is so
twisted
what are you gonna do go out there now
oh
why'd you leave the room because I
didn't want to see that anymore it's
weird yeah it like now it begs the
question like I guess I'd always want to
keep him in my sight yeah or would I
if you didn't have sound then yes
okay let it out
breathe
what no what was she just trying to see
I think she's trying to like set off the
car alarm
so somebody would come
the range on those keys is really bad
nope careful
what is that oh okay
oh nope careful he's right there right
he did unlock it
oh
[Music]
dude the Firearms right there
oh
really good with the choreography
song her phone her phone her phone
that's what her plan was when she saw
that oh smart yeah
come on
oh
I'm dripping moist right now
it's good I knew I would have to pass
the mental oh my God yeah oh
not bad
come on push what's harder
oh yeah yeah
they're coming it's all part of the game
man
of course he's got it
that is so condescending
where is he
sounds like he's yeah yeah okay creeping
in
a nice like split frame this is darker
than Game of Thrones
I feel like maybe if I were her I would
get out of the house I don't know that
you're safer inside the house
oh
I think I just gave bad advice she
sensed her vibrations
especially out here it's going to be
like a noisitorium
just start jumping up and down
don't don't breathe
no that's about a blind guy
this is horrifying yeah cat Mouse man
no I don't like this no no don't don't
move don't [__] move don't oh no
no
no no no no no no no no no
stop no no no
stop stop ugh
yeah what do you do oh yeah I shot an
arrow right past her
oh who is she now running to running
zigzags to go back in the house yeah all
right I'm sorry I gave you bad advice my
girl it's all your fault I hate to sound
like my grandma but I do wish that they
made this a little brighter it's like I
can't tell what is going on
no no no no no no no no no no no feet
first are you what are you kidding me
you dive out whatever you're kidding me
no
I'm torn roof is kind of better maybe
until he gets up there no he's got
arrows bro
maybe take your shoes off
then you have no shoes on
other problems what's that red thing
whoa
hahaha
smart I mean so far she's pretty
resourcing very smart and in a way that
feels relatively plausible because she's
a novelist that's right it's her job to
think of all the possible outcomes seven
it's just seven endings
no
crawl up to the peak
no not not be no uh
do you shoot her yeah I know I knew it I
knew it right in our IT band I knew it I
knew it I knew it
good flexibility there really good no
he's gonna climb the trellis now
she but she has one now
I don't really because it's a modern
Arrow well you know the one that you can
actually pull out without jacking
yourself up more Oh I thought you said
modern era like she could get help at
the hospital after class this isn't it
like 1600s
yes
do you know how to use that
no
what are you gonna do right now boo drop
it on his head and still do a lot of
damage
oh boy come on oh come on no no no no no
close the window crank that Soldier Boy
no no no
yes
learning how to do it
he's like touche not bad touche
Mademoiselle you're not gonna pray for
death as quickly as I thought
I'm sure this isn't the most of her
worries right now but I don't like her
taking off her pants near him
yeah
I mean if you don't have it I'm saying
it's not the most of her worries right
now but
so where are you supposed to tie like
above it below it I guess what right
above it that's what I would think right
yeah but I actually don't know how the
blood flow works in your legs
fire off a practice shot so we know that
you know how it works yeah let's do a
training montage
oh that's uh his kill list 13 huh
she's trying to figure out how it works
or yeah
[Music]
yeah oh no Jesus Christ
John I knew John would come we always
show up right at the end
boyfriend
oh no
hey look on your head okay on your knees
oh this is a guy I responded to a call
there's someone inside he came running
past me knocked me cold I woke up
without my phone or my radio I need to
call for backup oh no jeez
can I use your phone call for backup I
should have called it in when I first
got here there you go
all right he's gonna break it doesn't
have a lock on that thing yeah I got a
719 here at 811 Fairhope signs a
possible forced entry suspect is at
large on foot what's the tell
the phone yeah of course yeah sorry so
stupid of me oh no oh no what's your
habits
oh what was I must be his girlfriend's
earring but was that intentional you
said you responded to a call was that
from Maddie from dispatcher they said
someone uh had called it in yeah because
she wouldn't be able to make that call
she's deaf mute
stop saying your thoughts out loud well
I guess it must have been your
girlfriend then made the call I was a
pretty clumsy lie there yeah you know I
can't swear to it but yeah you know I'm
pretty sure she has a spare key in that
uh planner oh no Porsche down there no
no no uh it's right down there on that
corner
John actually looks familiar too for
sure trashed your car pretty good huh
oh yeah look at that geez call send a
text make a call didn't hear you said
yeah I think so I'm not sure oh no don't
be too obvious with that rock yeah you
were not built for this guy
[Music]
whoa I knew it knew it
easy ah
damn it it's done it's done it's
done oh no
that was tough it's okay it's okay it's
okay
oh
nice nice shot there
my dude got this one like horror movie
I'm not quite dead jump yeah cause he
doesn't know his girlfriend's dead
either Ron
can read his lips from all the way over
there
I can only stumble
no no wow
[Music]
this is the image that she's having one
of the endings yeah she's playing them
out in her head this isn't real
[Music]
you can't run
yeah
yeah work it out like a story
take control the narrative
oh no I would have maybe tried to go out
there and kill him while he was being
strangled crossbow but that has to be a
perfect shot and the heart or in the
brain part or the brain anything else is
not gonna cut it don't cut it
hide it hiding bedroom bathroom loft
loft doesn't have any cover no doors to
barricade in his best case scenario he
doesn't find you and you bleed to death
oh
back outside I've tried that once who
knows you already tried that once
there's not a lot of room to maneuver he
figures out you're there
do the classic Horror DVD poster sooner
or later he is coming in here he knows
I'm bleeding out once he is in this
house it is over he is bigger stronger
and faster harder better aren't you
Kanye me right now a death punching you
all right
and we can't wait right you go outside
you're dead this is a really really well
done right now whoa
yeah if you were a better writer this
wouldn't be happening which means
there's only one ending he won't expect
he can't run hide or wait you gotta kill
him
and vitamin what does that leave join
I'll kill him I said that first I said
kill him in the message I didn't know
which way they were
vitamin for intimate dialogue
[__]
oh hey there
you want a cigarette your kitty kitty is
he gonna use her to try to lure
who's there
there hurt the kitty
welcome home puss you're gonna see mommy
very soon
in hell at least you'll see you
ugh down to the front oh yeah damn
quality shot
but that's not killing it what what what
ow oh
[Music]
ah
ow oh my god oh
jeez
oh I've actually never seen a hand that
mangled ever before in my entire life I
feel like I could vomit maybe one other
time but yeah oh
Gotten Good at picky hand gags lately in
horror Cinema
I'm coming in she did get him though he
might be bleeding too
come at me bro
[Music]
oh last remaining finger to give you the
bird
write him a message
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love her you think you're so tough
hahaha
to finish my book
if I died a day
let this be my last little Testament yes
smart
ah
what an incredible ending wow
oh ugh
hold on
[Music]
oh whoa
what what
those are glass shards
yeah
gnarly
but he's coming through the other way
yeah he just dropped into frame he's
right behind her
maybe she knows this
hi you know what
I feel his breath I think you're holding
out on me I bet if I hit the right spot
I can make you scream
you're one of those guys out this breath
yes yes
oh my God
nice
oh grab the other knife now here's the
job don't leave him with both of them
grabs the other night finish the job
work the killer bounce out to Tony Baker
work hand is so effing gnarly yeah and
when I look at it I like can't I get
Phantom pains
sympathetic pains yeah I feel like I've
been holding myself this whole movie
oh oh
no she's pretending maybe
I think she's just exhausted
what was it it's like oh wow
clever girl this is good very good yeah
yeah
yup yup yup
I am obsessed with her
go for it
[Applause]
it's okay these things are so
disorienting
come on we're so close
pop is cork
wrist get him in the wrist maybe they're
gonna do the endings again oh
[Music]
oh
come on come on
with the pull out do you think they're
both gonna die right now God that has to
be a unique kind of pain
oh
if I were her that's like the proudest
I'd ever be in my whole life I mean yeah
right also she wrote that thing like
show me the money or give me the money
whatever write this story babe you end
up rich yeah
you're back my phone
who do you call
resisting the urge
you call the cops
Ghostbusters they got help with this
situation no you should call us Craig
that's who she called
the cops show up what the hell happened
what the hell happened here
oh good
that's right she did uh hit him right in
the nick of time
her hand that's gonna need so many
surgeries this is the bluest cop car
you got a little peace of mind
huh really good well done good job Mike
Flanagan and Katie Siegel she wrote it
she co-wrote it damn that's really cool
wow wow that was on team really really
great work oh I dug the heck out of that
that was really cool that was so oh he
edited his wow yeah he did he always
added his own stuff I didn't even know I
think that's the thing yeah I think
that's a Mike Flanagan thing or at least
a lot of his stuff certainly you would
think with a script like this you kind
of would need to because there's so few
words yeah right he just kind of he
wrote it and was like I don't know what
I'm doing yeah I'm gonna write it so
much of this has to be in yeah in the in
the choreography and then the other
careful assembly and editing did that
meet your expectations knowing some of
Mike Flanagan's other work
yeah I mean you know this this to me is
like okay earlier Mike Flanagan before
you know stuff like Hill House that that
I know him the best for uh and I thought
it did nicely to play off of you know
you see this and and being familiar with
some of the advertising you're like oh
there's a home invasion sort of slasher
movie and I think they did a nice job to
present to themselves very much that way
uh John Gallagher Jr I wonder if he oh
and Michael wait wait wait John
Gallagher Jr is
was that Friday night what is he from
he's from Walmart what is it I gotta
look I got I think he did a movie that a
friend of ours wrote what is it not
mistaken uh uh uh the vanishing of
Sydney Hall is the name of that movie I
don't know about that one but I got
Logan Lerman I think I've met him before
like I really feel like I know know this
oh 10 Cloverfield Lane sure there you go
exactly there you go yeah that's what it
is okay where's where's the John actor
from because I know I've seen him too
okay let's check it out we gotta find
all of this right now so uh he Michael
uh trucko trucko
um okay I don't know any of these hunter
killer next he's been in a lot of stuff
but I I definitely recognize him from
something oh he was in the Midnight Club
also midnight mass all right so Wow Mike
Flanagan uses all the same over and over
again oh he was in disjointed that's
what I know him from did you watch that
Netflix show disjointed he was uh he
owned the place next door and they had a
whatever oh he was great in that okay
yeah but yeah I like the way that this
like played off of what I came to expect
from knowing at least the trailer and
and did a thing where it's like I could
like Mike Flanagan certainly seems like
you know one of the you know current
people you turn to for like a good
Stephen King quality thing or uh a good
um uh what is her name who wrote Hill
house uh you know either way I think you
you turn to him for those sort of Gothic
more literary feeling things and this
was cool because it had all those
Pleasures you want out of a home
invasion slasher movie there are a lot
of things that do remind me of something
like the strangers but I also really
appreciated that
um and I also thought of like you're
next as well and I like that this kind
of yeah deconstructs a little bit of the
home invasion the slasher but but does
it in a way where you know instead of
resting on the mystery of the mask and
the iconography they really just make it
like a a real cat and mouse two
characters on either side of a wall
basically you know know trying to outwit
one another
and and so yeah like by the end it
started out and I was like okay look
I've seen versions of this movie before
and this is doing it pretty well but by
the end I was like oh this is actually
pretty neat like you take off the
Killer's mask right away like he becomes
a character and it's all about sort of
watching them you know back and forth as
they try to figure each other out and
then you have the additional element of
of yeah the limited uh you know sound
and whatnot and her not being able to
hear and having to be resourceful in
different ways I'm super with you on
that he has not missed for me yet like
no I I'm very consistent I didn't think
this was going to be the first one to
miss but like you said it kind of has a
basic premise as opposed to some of his
other ones that have more layers he is
to me I don't know if other people talk
about him this way but he I know him for
doing things in the horror space but
also
um like religious horror I would almost
call it and this didn't have that second
element this was this wasn't like
um I've teen Hill House blind Manor
midnight mass and Midnight Club I love
all four of those for different reasons
but they all have like a second thing
and this kind of just is what it is so I
was it's very straightforward yeah so I
was kind of curious okay because it was
his earlier work because he probably
didn't have as big of a budget because
there's not that many people in the cast
am I gonna just be underwhelmed by this
but I wasn't because the suspense is
there the whole time and the the way
that they it was shot and
um how believable her character is Katie
Siegel's character is just so Maddie
that's the character how believable
Maddie is because she's never out
fighting him she's never like you know
sometimes all of a sudden you'll see in
these movies there will then just be
this person who significantly smaller
and less strong just like sucker punch
somebody and you're like that's not how
that would work here she's outsmarting
him and she's a novelist and so at every
turn even with the multiple endings or
whatever I'm just sitting there thinking
this is really smartly done oh that was
so good I really dug that yeah and
they're not making her unbelie they're
not to me at least and again I would be
curious to hear what you know a deaf
viewer's take might be on a movie like
this but I feel like they haven't uh
gone so far as to make it like oh yeah
there's this like badass moment where
she like suits up and all of a sudden
she can hear and sense everything via
vibrations in there like you know they
kept everything uh really it felt like
conscientious to her situation and to
you know the few assets she has at her
disposal being inside the house and
having that space to work with and then
yeah really having to kind of
figure this guy out and Yeah like her
being a writer is another like really
Stephen King flourish but I really like
the way that they put uh her sort of
thought process on display and the way
that they you know had her Express in
various different ways and and use the
range of um uh what's her name Katie
Siegel like her abilities
um but yeah I thought she really
inhabited that role really well and
she's like a hard one final girl because
again like this has made me think in in
moments of something like again the
strangers or or you're next and your
next certainly has that thing where it's
like the heroine emerges as this badass
and that's really fun I haven't seen
either and that's it works for that
movie they're worth a watch okay um but
yeah like this I thought like was a real
tooth and nail struggle and I thought
that while it's not like the deepest
character piece or whatever I always
felt connected to Maddie and I always
you know was like really in the
intensity of the moment with her why do
you think they included Craig
I think it's just one of those things to
give you a red herring it's something to
give her story a little bit more just
flavor because now you know like okay
she's got this relationship that is you
know clearly in the past but not
entirely could he be the killer could he
be somebody who's going to show up later
and maybe get killed uh yeah I think
it's mostly yeah just like a character
beat slash red herring and I mean for me
like that worked because I was sitting
here going look quick go show up me too
I kept saying he's like she's called him
a couple times he's called back a few
times maybe he'll just get concerned but
yeah like it worked that he didn't show
up I wonder if there was ever a version
of the script in which he did but I feel
like it was enough to have John show up
because that was realistic his wife is
missing yeah it's like it makes a lot of
sense and we'd also I don't think we
need as much of them being like
what's going on like you know him
showing up and them trying to have a
scene and you know that if that happens
maybe something about their relationship
I mean like I trust Mike Flanagan as a
writer uh and and clearly Katie Siegel's
like Shepherd at this as well so like if
they had chosen to go that way I feel
like it could have been fine it could
work but I didn't think it needed it
whatsoever yeah I agree with you I I
also think that a lot of horror movies a
lot of movies in general have a really
hard time knowing when to end yeah and I
when when she's sitting on the porch and
she sees the cop cars I was like oh are
we gonna have to do a jump to like
something else and it was like I don't
want to do that because this was this
full story she did it she made it like I
don't need to see her in the cast yeah I
don't need to see her with her sister
later on like I don't need to see any of
those things yeah she this was like a
one Mission how does it end and and the
premise the setup of this movie being
that conversation of her writing the
novel not knowing how that ends yeah and
then this having kind of the perfect
ending yeah I thought was really just
yeah perfectly done perfectly done yeah
it's it's it's the exact right kind of
ending for a story like this that again
is like it's got nice little uh nuances
that clearly demonstrate the care that
they've put into this but it's not
trying to be so deep and heavy that it's
not appropriate just to end on that sigh
of relief like we made it she's gonna be
fine you know finally help is coming
that midnight mass
what's it called candidmo what's it
called you see something and then
something else
like it's like a reference
Easter egg was interesting too I wonder
but this was before that I think yeah
yeah it definitely must have been
so uh I wonder then if that was if they
had already been he's populating or
whatever yeah I mean if it if it showed
up in this I have to imagine it was
something that's been on his mind for a
while and then yeah like with the
success of this and the success of other
things like Oculus and of course Hill
house
um yeah I think through all that you
know he probably got to realize that
dream project or whatever yeah um yeah
but that was cool when you spotted that
and even something like the Stephen King
novel that we see and I was like yeah
paying homage to all the other creepy
creepy weirdo yeah because this did
nicely to be like what if home invasion
slasher movie but instead of going
schlock we go Stephen King about it it's
sort of like how I felt it's like yeah
you've got a writer you have the unique
I think the most you know unique aspect
people latched on to is the element of
oh you have a a person who can't uh hear
the full spectrum of everything around
her and so that's going to be you know
both the positive and a negative I love
the way it came around at the end too
with fire alarm and using you know the
directly opposite you know uh uh you
know state of being for the two of them
as like a weapon in that moment I
thought was like a cool beat and and
that we don't get too much of a deep
dive like I really liked watching uh uh
your boy as the killer guy because you
don't get a crazy deep dive explanation
on him he doesn't have some kind of
Grudge that we know about you know he is
it is that strangest thing of just like
I'm just out here doing this man and
like to me you know again a great
explanation is great but also for a
movie like this I think it's appropriate
sometimes to just be like that's pretty
horrifying because sometimes again lots
of stuff happens in the world I'm not
gonna say this is realistic but you know
some Prowler could just pop up at your
house in the woods and you know torture
you for a little while I feel like all
the explanation that I needed was the 13
tally marks to me that was this is who
he is this is what he does this is Sport
this is game you know yeah it's that to
me showed okay so we're not gonna get a
backstory this is nothing to do with her
he was not coming after something
specific this is not a robbery this is
the 13th kill on his list yeah and I
love that they included that one little
moment that just makes you know that's
what's up with this guy this is what he
does and he hasn't been caught yet and
that's also what makes her be like I
have to type out those notes yeah
because if I because I'm if I die more
than likely 14 I needed to be the the
last one yeah that moment when she
started typing I got really teary-eyed
because I think that the the I went out
like I died fighting or whatever like
your last thoughts that you want your
family to know yeah is like get this
mother effort and also I just so you
guys know I went down like the Baddie
that I am as opposed to like your family
always having to wonder what happened
here you think about like getting that
note as a family member and just yeah
being horrified but also so proud of
somebody that that's what they did I
don't know that was a really bizarrely
emotional mode they don't have the
presence to be like this is my life I
might be on the way out not your two
hands John yeah it was certainly not so
gross yeah that was a question I wonder
how they did that yeah
they certainly at least had a prosthetic
for part of it the strong hand child was
there anything that was lacking for you
anywhere that you were like I really
wish that they had done this or this not
really yeah me neither no I mean this is
one of those ones where I remember at
the time people like oh my God this
movie is so amazing and I'm like yeah
it's really good I really liked it and I
think it's really conscientiously done
I'm not like this is my favorite horror
movie but I'm like yeah this is solid
it's really well made it's it's
thoughtful it's got some nice flourishes
it's well shot without being like
you know there's that one shot where she
goes to the door and you get that big
tilt and that's kind of you know like an
eccentric shot but it's not like a James
Wan movie which I like James Wan movies
I like his style but it's much more
kinetic and much more
um you know sort of roller coastery uh I
thought this had the right amount of
that I really like the music I liked the
use of you know diegetic sound in and
out going from her perspective to then
being able to hear the environments and
two I mean even though in the studio
it's not always easy to deal with low
light photography I liked a lot of that
stuff too so um well on that note should
we hush what's hush unless you got
anything else to tell the world just
really good it was really really great
I'm glad that we watched it that's the
coolest thing about doing this is that
movies that I probably because this was
on Netflix and off of net whatever that
I probably never would have gotten
around to it I'm so glad that I did I
love seeing simple stories like this
being told brilliantly well and that's
what story told well and yeah and final
thought yeah spending that time with the
Killer and really making him a character
and watching as he like comes up with
the story to tell to John like I thought
that stuff was really nice because you
have all the requisite like he's not a
Hulk he's not like teleporting around
he's not silent and he's off but in a
more like tangible way where you're just
like he's like kind of bored and he's
like playing with his food and he's like
semi amused by this stuff but you can
tell like yeah like that's
that's an unhinged guy that could
actually exist you know yeah yeah it's a
good impression Well Ron joxie has done
it again Ron jocks he's done it again
yeah that thank you for watching hush
with us you guys are awesome thank you
for being amazing rejects uh and we will
be back with drippy moist in the future
moist he'll be back and hey before we go
on WE shout out a patron they shot
shout out to Kevin smart listen Kevin
here's the deal number one you're smart
you're smart there's actually I don't
want to live up to anything better in
the world you could be than smart
because then you could be all the other
things if you're smart you can be smart
enough to be kind you can be smart
enough to be good you can be smart
enough to be great true also because the
Celtics just traded away Marcus Smart
and I love him so much and so you share
a last name yeah so now I just needed
that smart back in my life so that's why
it's super sexy shout out to you that's
a smart shout out there Roxy looking
smart today
Boston and smash smash your wicked smack
Kevin
how do you like them apples Kevin oh I
could say it because I'm one of them it
just is the trashiest sounding accent
ever I'm so sorry to turn your beautiful
floated one of the sexiest accents on a
thing I was reading by Liars
100 of liars agree that's bad uh but
you're not bad you're not bad at all
because you're Kevin and you're smart
you're Wicked yeah Kevin and you're
[__] smart
I love you buddy stay pledged